hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from round two of
defeated candidates tournament 2022. uh
it is the first game that finished and
it is a former world championship
championship challenger yanni pognish vs
former wheelchair championship
challenger fabian carwana both of them
have faced the magnus crossing in the
world chess championship match uh nepo
in um
in 2020 uh and of course fabiana corona
in 2018 and this is of course a very
very big clash and as it often is um
especially when fabi is playing okay
probably the most complicated games i've
ever seen are the ones uh that fabi
plays sometimes the ones that the dink
plays and of course uh i'm not counting
the one that do both plays uh because
those moves are impossible to calculate
but from the moves that are possible to
calculate uh i'm pretty sure fabi plays
the most complicated chess and even in
the
candidates tournament here where you
have so much time there's so much time
control you can win additional time
after reaching 40 then you get more you
know when you reach more 60 there was
just not enough time to
uh you know continue this game uh but uh
it's incredibly complicated and
incredibly enjoyable so so many awesome
lines let's dive straight into it but
i'm pretty sure i will be uh showing
another game as soon as i show this one
because uh well uh
you know the boards are starting to
catch fire so nipple with the white
pieces opens with e4 with e5 by fabi
knight to f3 knights to c6 and bishop to
c4 and of course the fabi plays knight
to f6 he avoids the evans gambit by go
by not going bishop to c5 d3 and now
bishop to c5 we have castles d6 and now
c3 saw a very uh standard line of the
joko pianissimo yeah we have a6 and now
pawn to a4 we have bishop back to a7 and
now rook to e1 so again this is all very
very standard stuff we have h6 here uh
knight beat the d2 and now we have g5
and this although it looks like a very
aggressive move it's um it's a pretty
standard idea many uh
incredibly strong players have played
this move uh for example wesley so i
played it against vladimir kramnik he
defeated him in in the granchester blitz
tournament in paris uh also uh magnus
cross and played this move against
sergey karjakin uh the game ended in a
draw they played it in the london chess
classic in 20
uh so it's uh definitely uh
a very interesting move castles is by
far the more popular one but the g5 is
also very much played so of course b4 uh
when your opponent does something on the
king side uh feel free to push that b4
it's winning free space on the queen
side and now uh there are a couple of
moves that were played in this position
for example wesley still played knight
stage seven against vladimir kramnik in
the game that we mentioned uh mentioned
magnus cross and played knight to the h5
here in the game against karakin that we
mentioned also g4 is a known move so
there are a couple of um
very strong ideas here but fabi goes for
the one that was never played and it's
already a very very interesting one and
that is knight the g4 so already as of
move 10 we have a completely new game
and uh it's basically a move that we
whenever we do a you know an italian
game doesn't really matter which line i
always say that it doesn't make sense to
play bishop to g4 a knight to g4 to go
after the f2 pawn because white can just
play rook to e2 and you don't really
have anything here and what better move
to play than the one that no one plays
in the candidates tournament so really
good stuff by fabi uh here rook to e2 uh
just or you could play rook to f1 but
that's just you know moving the rook
back to where it came from you know you
would rather admit admit defeat than do
do that so rook to e2 and now queen to
f6 fabi going very aggressive against
this f2 pawn queen to e1 by nepo and the
now queen to g7 sort of fianchettoing
your queen
knights to f1 and now we have castles by
fabi knight to g3 and knight to e7 now
so you always have to uh you know worry
about whether the king will sidestep
this this diagonal where f5 is coming uh
those are those are very very uh
critical ideas here so here d4 best way
to counter
an attack on the kings that is the
counter attack in the center so they say
he captures on d for nc captures on d4
and now the real question is why is nepo
offering the uh d4 pawn is it just uh is
it just a free pawn well if you capture
it for example bishop captures on d4 you
would not have a a a very good time for
example knight
even better you don't have to capture
right away you play rook to a3 and this
is just a full mobilization of your
pieces it seems like a good idea to
capture because it's a bishop but this
is even stronger bishop goes back we're
going to push it back even further let's
say bishop to a7 and now we go for
knight to f5 attack the queen and once
we give up another pawn captures
captures and captures and now we play
bishop to b2 and we've fully mobilized
all of our pieces uh is it going to be
very very hard for black to play this
let's say queen h7 you play h3 and what
can black do
that's not not the greatest of positions
probably knight captures on f2 uh
but uh even this will leave white with
it with a better position real captures
we're gonna play rook eight eight of
course the rook can always be captured
queen d2 lasik captures for example
captures here queen captures now c6 and
the game continues
with white having very very good chances
so uh bishop captures on d4 isn't really
the way to go so fabi goes knight to c6
puts more pressure on the d4 pawn and
then now rook to a3 again you could play
bishop to b2 and it is possible to play
this where we just trade knight captures
knight captures bishop captures bishop
captures let's say queen captures and
rook to c1
you do get some development in but
it's not uh not as scary but never not
interested in that he goes to rook to a3
uh now the rook can always be shifted
over to the king side to help out with
the attack and now fabi grabs the pawn
and it is in fact the strongest move
here knight captures on the e4 knight
captures the bishop captures and now
pawn to h3 challenging the knight here
knight to e5 and now bishop back to a2
so he gave up a pawn but he has a very
very strong bishop and also once he
kicks away this bishop and this bishop
assumes this diagonal is gonna be it's
gonna be basically a bishop pair from
hell uh and now fabi could continue with
something like bishop to e6 the counter
the light square bishop right away but
he strikes with c5 first he wants to
take care of the situation in the center
on the queen side and then uh he he
really doesn't have all that much to
worry about b characters on c5 bishop
captures on c5 now attacking the rook
here and rook to b3
asking uh fabi what do you play now and
he just plays b5 uh bishop to e6 looks
nice but then the b7 pawn hangs so here
b5 uh knight to f5 now going after the
queen and five he just moves it you
could capture it right away for example
captures captures and just go for the
cold-blooded b captures on a4 uh but
after rook the g3 it's um
it's very much playable but maybe you
don't want to do this it is the
candidates tournament after all so first
queen to f6 we're going to prepare the
capture on f5 properly king to h2 uh
moving the king away from this diagonal
and now b captures an a4 so giving up a
pawn but rook to g3 and now you have to
worry about a lot of things the bishop
is attacking g5 h4 could happen f4 could
happen so many
uh moves are possible here so fabi plays
king the h7 gets the king away from the
g file and this is the uh moment where
you could like spend really an eternity
calculating lines uh because i'm just
gonna show uh
one very special one uh that did not
happen in the game and that is pawn to
f4 and this is such a beautiful forced
line that
well it could have been a game of its
own so g captures an f4 we're going to
play bishop captures on f4 and now put a
lot of pressure on that h6 pawn so we
have to capture bishop captures on f5
bishop captures on e5 first queen
captures e captures and now you can't
capture the f5 pawn because bishop to b1
uh wins the queen so you're going to
have to move the queen queen f4 now
we're going to play bishop captures on
f7 a complete mess of a position rook
captures on f7 now rook to e7 going for
the attack and here we're going to play
rook to f8 but now pawn to f6 of course
you can
do just anything here and uh you have to
capture this pawn so queen captures an
f6 now queen to e4 with check king the
h8 and now rook to e6 going after the h6
pawn and here we will get this complete
and madness uh
of a position where you you have a
couple of options like maybe d5 counter
attacking but the nicest one i believe
is bishop to f2 uh just giving up the
queen and after rook captures on f6
bishop captures with check king captures
now rook to g7 with check you even allow
rook to g6 it seems like you've
blundered the game but just rook
captures on g6 and if queen captures we
just uh
capture the queen and then of course our
a pawn is winning so you have you're
going to have to move the king let's say
rook to g8 and you get some sort of a
position that is queen against two rooks
with black having so many pawns uh it's
a draw because there's no way you're
gonna checkmate the white king with your
own king being so wide in the open but i
mean it's just it's just beautiful but
nipple uh decides that it is uh too too
uh risky to go for that and you don't
really gain anything uh so he plays
queen to d1 and queen to d1 is one of
those moves that does nothing but uh
also does everything it's full of
possibilities and it just allows fabi uh
to very easily make a mistake uh what is
what is happening here with uh
uh the king side uh well here fabi
played bishop to d7 and he wants to of
course activate the bishop he wants to
connect the rooks and he's inviting
nepot to a sacrifice on h6 which looks
possible you have all this pressure on
g5 but it doesn't work let's say knight
captures queen captures you're going to
capture on g5 just queen h5 and there is
no good way for white to continue this
attack and black's pieces are very very
harmonious rook is coming to g8 you will
not gain anything from this so instead
we have rook to c2 another very very
tricky move by nipple uh just asking
fabi what do you play now and the real
idea behind this is that um
well you you always have this pressure
against the bishop so let's say if the
knight moves we can capture the bishop
and then the bishop and d7 fall so there
are ideas like this it's a very unlikely
that this will happen uh but the real
reason the rook the c2 was played is
that the queen gets access to the h5
square and now let's say five you play
something like a5 it's a silly move but
just to show you the threats bishop
captures and g5 just wins on the spot
now because after h captures queen h5
check and his game over king j8 rook
captures on g5 with the check and you
can't really block with knight to g6
because the f7 pawn doesn't really exist
so just rook captures and that's it we
win the queen uh it's game over queen
captures queen captures of course uh
that's it resigns so here fabi says all
right that's a very impressive idea but
uh i'm not actually going to fall for
that so bishop captures on f5 he just
eliminates one of the uh
main threats the the knight on f5 and
now e captures on f5 and rook a2 b8 this
is how fabi plays this uh the situation
on the clock which i think is very
important uh for this game uh 34 minutes
for nipple and 24 minutes for fabi uh
and uh just queen to h5 did you really
expect any other move uh from from
yanipanishi uh and uh
again uh can you capture an f5 that's
the question no no you can't if queen
captures an h5 now comes the uh rook
captures on c5 idea that
that is also one of the possibilities
with the rook being on c2 uh
as the queen is attacking it so you have
to move the rook with tempo d captures
on c5 now rook captures on g5 and of
course black resigns if queen f6 we just
capture on e5 and there is no move you
can make here the bishop there is simply
too strong
there is no defending this position
so after queen h5 rook the g8 was played
by fabi
uh and now comes bishop to b2 uh finally
nepal's bishop's pair is fully
operational okay maybe not fully
operational it would be better if for
example this pawn disappeared and the
bishop came to b1 but even this is uh
incredible uh but here we have rook g
the e8 by fabi bishop back to c1 again
putting pressure on this g5 pawn and
fabi defends it again we have bishop to
b2
rook cheetah e8 and here bishop to c1
and incredible as it is he was in this
position on move 33 that iannipo nishi
and fabiana corona agreed to a draw as
well i'm not going to say there is
nothing to be done here because there
are a couple of moves that fabi could
have considered and of course he did
consider them he just uh i i think he
was already below 10 minutes on the
clock and he just did not want to push
this it's only move 33 in an incredibly
sharp position
uh so a draw is is definitely fitting
here but i will just show you one line
that is uh well so full of possibilities
instead of um
instead of repeating rook g to e8 we
capture the bishop here rook captures on
b2 and now uh okay the next move is
force we have to capture back now we
play a3 okay we get a protected pass
spawn on a3 now the rook has to move
where does the rule go if you move away
from the b file then black wins the b
file if you play rook to b7 which is
definitely strongest you keep the b file
uh you
promote your rook to a pig you put extra
pressure on f7 it's not a problem bishop
captures on f2 we attack the rook okay
we give up the pawn on a3 rook captures
on a3 and now that this is probably uh
the position
you get when you start calculating at
that position where fabia agreed to a
draw but then if you had a little bit
more time on the clock and we're willing
to invest a you find d5 and this is such
a scary move to face uh because now this
diagonal opens up and this is uh and of
course the pawn cannot be captured if
you captured upon queen d6 just wins
you're attacking the bishop and also
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries uh this is just resigns so
you would have to allow the past pawn to
survive you would have to play something
else g3 probably to
prevent all of these ideas
and now queen the c6 we attacked the
rook on b7 and there is no uh well
there's just no good good move to make
here uh what wha what do you play here
it's it's so uh i mean it's such a such
a terrible move if you play some silly
move then uh queen to c1 attacking the
rook on a3 and also threatening
checkmate on g1 uh there are so many
awesome moves here if you play rook to
b1 uh then there are even ideas of g4
and now the the the knight will be able
to come to
the g4 and there's no good move here if
you play something like pawn to h4 uh
then queen to c2 again attacking the
rook uh uh threatening all sorts of
nasty discoveries here and there's no
way to parry all the threats
but the real uh question is after let's
say queen to c6 what happens if we play
queen to e2 we give up a little bit of
material to eliminate this knight and
what happens then well this is the
actual line that we have to check queen
captures and b7 queen captures on e5 but
now okay we move the bishop back bishop
to a7 and even after bishop captures on
d5 we're going to play queen b5 pin the
bishop not allow bishop captures on f7
and now f6 trying to get this bishop to
e4 check in to maybe get a queen trade
but now king h8 and uh the real
evaluation of this position is that
black is just winning uh there's no way
to reach uh
the black king uh black is up in
material black is up upon he has a past
a pawn and the white king is also uh
completely uh in the open you have to be
very very careful even with perfect play
this position would be winning for fabi
but okay this is really just going uh uh
incredibly deep into the position uh you
know uh in in in a situation where fabi
did not have enough time to even
consider such things uh so yeah after
bishop to c1 they agreed to a draw and
maybe perhaps uh a chance was missed
here but that's just chess even with all
the time control in the candidates
tournament uh it was not enough time uh
for fabita to work all of this out as uh
i mean it is just impossible to
calculate but uh uh i i i hope you you
now see what i meant that uh one of the
you know the probably the most
complicated games that we see on this
channel are fabi's games
uh so yeah that's uh the game hope you
guys enjoyed it the first game that
finished in round two of the feeder
candidates tournament hope you guys
enjoyed it we are uh probably gonna show
another one very quickly as uh i i saw
that it was about um at the finish when
i started preparing this video i would
like to wish a very happy birthday at 11
i hope you had uh had a great day and i
would like to thank andrew lastova uh
johan derek king and aravind kumar
vandelli for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament until it finishes
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day